이런 부분에서 Solana 개발 꿀팁을 설명해 드렸고요.
대부냡 같은 경우에는 공개 1st hand이라는 데에서 받아야 되거든요, 수수료를.
그러니까 저희가 메인넷 같이 내가 Solana 직접 구매해서 트렌젝션을 보내는 곳이 아니기 때문에
이 대부냡은 공자 대부냡을 받아서 그걸 통해서 지지적으로 거래를 하시거나 해야 되는데
이게 하루에 0.5솔에서 5솔 정도까지 제한이 되어 있습니다.
그래서 사실은 굉장히 많은 양을 테스트 하시려면 조금 더 많은 양이 필요하시는데
그런 부분은 디즈코드에서 Solana 채널에다가 요청을 해 주시면
원하는 만큼 보내드릴 수 있도록 하겠습니다.
그런데 보통은 Solana 대본의 쏠의 양이 그렇게 많이 들지는 않을 거고요.
사실은 토큰을 발행하시면 그 토큰을 무한대로 발행하면 되시기 때문에
사실상은 이제 토큰을 조금 더 많이 사용해 주시면 감사하겠습니다.
그래서 이렇게 Solana 개발 쿨팁을 정리해 드렸고
해당 내용은 제가 Solana 채널에서 다시 한 번 정리를 해드리겠습니다.
이렇게 제가 조금 Solana에 대한 소개와
그리고 AI 에이전트 쪽에서 붙여서 어떤 것들을 할 수 있는 좀 소개를 드렸는데요.
그래서 저희가 실제 빌드위크가 한 3월 3일까지 요정되어 있는데
그때까지 혹시 질문이 있으시다면 편하게 디즈코드 채널 남겨주시면
제가 바로 답변 드릴 수 있도록 하겠습니다.
제가 지금 사실 뉴욕에 있어서 피타 적응을 아직 못 해가지고
굉장히 이제 잠에서 못 다시 못 한 상태로 발표는 하느라
굉장히 좀 말을 빨리 하고 그랬는데
혹시 뭔가 질문 있으시다는 편하게 디즈코드를 남겨주시면
제가 잘 답변 드릴 수 있도록 하겠습니다.
네 감사합니다.
네 피타에도 불구하고
정말 아주 블록진 모르시는 분들도
하나 다 이해할 수 있도록 너무 자세하게 잘 설명을 해 주셨습니다.
네 그러면 저희 이렇게 오늘 세션 다 들어보셨는데요.
이제 Q&A 시간입니다.
오늘 세션이나 해커청 전반에 대해서 궁금하신 분들이 있으면
채널 남겨주시면 저랑 오늘 세션을 했었던 분들이
이제 같이 답변을 드리도록 하겠습니다.
혹시 뭐 궁금한 적 있으실까요?
마이크를 켜서 말씀을 주셔도 되고요.
Q&A를 넘겨주시는 저희가 읽어서 답변드릴 수 있습니다.
편하게 질문 부탁드립니다.
그리고 디즈코드도 있으니까요.
디즈코드 전체 채널에서
많이 질문해 주시면 감사하겠습니다.
이번 해커청에서 기대하는 결제 플로우의 예시다
피다실 중심인지
X40이나 솔라나 페이까지 폭넓게 봐주시는지 궁금합니다.
네 제가 답변 드리자면
피다실 아니더라도 X40이나 솔라나 페이까지
사용하셔도 무방합니다.
결제 레이어로서 솔라나를 사용해 주신다면
사실은 피다실 X40이 솔라나 페이 사용하지 않습니다.
X40, X40, 솔라나 페이 사용하지 않으셔도
그냥 스마트 컨트롤 자체적으로 구현하셔도
크게 문제 없습니다.
추가 질문입니다.
기존 오픈소스나 기존 프로젝트를
기반으로 확장해서 참여해도 괜찮은지 궁금합니다.
구글 플라도 AR 활용한
재미나의 호출 수준인가 충분한지
아니면 ADK 벌칙스 같은
구조적 활용까지 들어가면 더 유리한지도 궁금합니다.
네 제가 답변드리겠습니다.
먼저 기존 오픈소스나 기존 프로젝트를
기반을 확장해서 참가해도 괜찮습니다.
크게 문제 없습니다. 하지만 사실상
AI 에이전트로를 사용하는 데 있어서
당일성이 명확히 명시가 되어야 하고
기존에 있던 어떤 문제점을 해결했는지
그리고 어떤 대상으로 나오는 프로덕트
및 프로젝트인지를 이렇게 말씀을 해 주셔야
저희가 잘 이해할 수 있을 것 같습니다.
그리고 구글 클라우드 AR 활용한
재미나의 호출 수준은 충분한지
ADK나 벌칙스 같은
구조적 활용까지 들어가면 더 유리한지
사실은 뭔가 저희가
오버 솔루션을 원하는 건 아닙니다.
그래서 원하시는 주제가 있고
그 주제를 실제로
어떤 풀고 싶으신 문제가 있고
그 문제는 솔루션이 있으시고
그 솔루션이 그 문제를 해결하는 데에 있어서
명확하면 어떤 기술 스텍을 사용하든
꼭 복잡하거나 구체적인
기술 스텍을 사용하지 않으셔도 모박합니다.
라이브 시안이가 실제 데모제 출시해서
애는 메인넷을 사용해야 하나요?
아니면 대브넷으로 충분한가요?
대브넷으로 충분합니다.
메인넷은 돈이 들어간 애톡이기 때문에
추천드리지 않습니다.
그리고 대브넷의 경우에는
퍼셋을 따로 그냥 해코넛 용어로
이렇게 할 고민 중인데
근데 또 디노스에 좀 위험이 있어서
제가 추천된 거는
해코넛 참여를 결정하신 분은
대브넷솔을 최대한 빠르게 요청을 해주시면
만약에 뭐 해코넛도 마감 몇 시간 전에
뭔가 이렇게 빠르게 하셔야 하는 상황을
조금 피해 하실 수 있지 않을까 생각합니다.
그래서 솔라나 대브넷을 요청은
계속 받고 있기 때문에
제가 따로 채널을 그냥 솔라나 관련 질문이 아니라
다른 채널을 열어둬서
거기서 계속 지급을 드리도록 하겠습니다.
제가 티켓을 열어서 요청 주실 수 있는
채널을 하나 만들겠습니다.
추가적인 질문이 없는 것 같아서
여기서 마무리 해도 괜찮을 것 같습니다.
구글 밑으로 질문을 주신 분들이 있어서
세 개만 더 받을게요.
재미나이가 아닌 클럽으로 개발을 진행할 때
재미나이처럼 연동을 해서 개발할 수 있나요?
혹시 제가 잠깐 끊겨서 못 들은다
다시 한 번 말씀해 줄 수 있을까요?
네.
재미나이가 아닌 클로드로 개발을 진행할 때
재미나이처럼 연동을 해서 개발할 수 있나요?
네. 동일합니다.
코덱스든 클로드든
페이다 셀 게이트웨이로 호출할 수 있습니다.
구글 클라우즈 신규 사용자가 아니어도
크레딧을 제공받을 수 있는지 궁금합니다.
이건 제가 답변드릴게요.
이게 신규 개정에 한해서만 300분이 크레딧이 지금이 되거든요.
그래서 신규로 등록을 해주셔야 될 것 같습니다.
네. 감사합니다.
그러면 시연이나 제출 시에는
레인넷을 사용할 필요는 없는 건가요?
이 부분에 대해서는 아까 전에
대분에 사용해도 된다라고 하셔서
괜찮을 것 같습니다.
그리고 구글 클라우즈 플랫폼 300크레디 지원을 해주신다고 하셨는데
에아의 이전트 지용지원은 따로는 없나요?
아까 지연님이 설명을 주셨는데
재미나이 쓰시면 초반에 지원되는 크레딧이 1부 있거든요.
그래서 그걸로 활용을 하시고
초과되는 것에 대해서는
만약에 초과가 된 것 같다고 하면
하지만 디스코드에 말씀을 주시면
제가 따로 크레딧은 부여해드리는 방향으로
한번 해보도록 할게요.
혹시 저희 추가 질문 있을까요?
크리스티는 혹시 저희 추가 질문 있는지
한번 확인 가능하실까요?
저희가 구글 인콜 메시지가 안 보이는 것 같아서
추가 질문 없다고 전달을 받았습니다.
개발을 꼭 안티그랩디치나 구글 관련 생팩에서
진행해야 한 가단점을 주거나 하는 것이 있을까요?
주로 크레딧코드로 개발하고 있어서요?
안티그랩디치나 재미나이를 사용하시면 너무 좋겠지만
저희가 결국적으로 에아의 이전트의 결제 환경을
이제 페이다시아이라든지
아니면 그런 것들을 활용하는데
조금 더 중점을 두고 있고
사실은 개발 과정에서 어떤
이런 에아의 플랫폼을 썼는지는
그게 중요하지 않을 것 같습니다.
그러면
저희도 질문이 없는 것 같아서
여기까지 이제
긴 시간 동안
세션 들어주셔서 너무 감사드리고요.
아, 디스코즈 링크는
네일로 보내주시나요?
디스코즈 링크 같은 경우는
제가 지금 일단 찍어놓도록 하겠습니다.
네, 여기 보시면
지금 핫고트넘 커뮤니티
혈코드 찍으셔서 들어가시면 될 것 같습니다.
그리고 이제 페이다시아에 대해서 잘 모르는데
ATR 87으로 인한
트럼프트 인젝션 공격 방지가 있나요?
저는 없는 걸로 알고 있는데
이 부분은 저도
페이다시아 개발자 분과 말씀 나누고
페이다시아 채널 좀 업데이트릴 수 있도록 하겠습니다.
제가 방금 확인을 해봤는데
결국적으로
개인킬 에이전트에게 주지 않고
유료 엔드 포인트에 도달했을 때는
이 사람의 생체 인증 승인이 필요하기 때문에
사실 그런 부분에서
프롬프트 인젝션을 막는다고
실제 기텀 래퍼 스토리에 명시를 하고 있는 것 같습니다.
혹시 또 있으실까요?
저희 사업 없으신 것 같고
아무래도 저희가 이제 핫고트 시작한지
4일 차가 됐고
이제 팀벨징이랑 준비하시느라
아직 방향 썩 이런 거 잡아가시는 것 같아서
오늘은 이것 이쯤으로 마무리를 하고
만약에 핫코톤에 관해서 더 궁금한 상황이 있거나
아니면 구글 클라우드, 솔라나 페이다시엘,
뭐 엑스다공이, 솔라나 테이
에 관해서 궁금한 점이 있으면
언제든지 저희 핫코톤 디스코드 활용해서
문의해 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
네, 그리고 이 핫코톤 디스코드
못 들어오시는 분들도 있을 것 같아서
저희 로마 공지로 보내드릴 내정이고요.
이 핫코톤 관련해서 지속적으로
철오그램, 안내라든지 이런 것들은
슈퍼팅, 코리아, 트위터, 링크등이 팔로우하시면
할 수 있습니다.
오늘 긴 시간 동안 들어주셔서
감사드리고 오늘 이렇게 좋은
세션을 해주신
포필러스, 유진영 리서치님
그리고 구글 클라우드, 판서나
솔뉴션 아키텍님 그리고 마지막으로
솔라나 재당
택, 택, 택, 김채린 매니저님한테
감사드립니다.
모두 감사의 인사드리고
핫코톤에서 좋은 성과를 내시길 바라겠습니다.
네, 편하게 나가주시면 될 것 같습니다.
네, 레코딩은 완료했습니다.
나중에 메일로 파일에 올 거여가지고
해당 파일 확인하면 될 것 같습니다.
고생 많으셨습니다.
네, 고생 많으셨습니다.